Richard Harrison famously known as old man on Pawn Stars has died after losing his battle with Parkinson's disease pretty good huh oh my god I wouldn't say this to my worst enemy the reality stars son Rick shared the sad news on Instagram Monday writing in part quote the old man Harrison passed away this morning surrounded by those he loved he will be tremendously missed by our family the team at Gold & Silver Pawn and his many fans the world over adding he was my hero and I was fortunate to get a very cool old man as my dad Richard moved to Vegas in the early 80s and opened the Gold & Silver Pawn Shop with his son when the producers found the family and turned their daily lives into a show it became an instant hit that is one of the stupidest statements I ever hated on Pawn Stars has been on the air since July 2009 with old man as one of the fan favorites though his appearances on the show over the last couple of years were less frequent